but you know what you know but at all
said and done we got through it we did
man yeah - oh look at you oh yeah you
like you've seen it I do i I've been
doing I've been doing it for twenty
something years and I love what I do
this is the first show that I have done
that I'm actually proud of and excited
about Wow
you know III I'm happy for my jobs I'm
happy to have done rules of engagement
for however long I made good money all
of that but from a creative standpoint
it's been fun but not like fulfilling
this even though it is a network comedy
it there's something special about it I
think yeah and I also um I even can tell
mmm I really did it can yeah there's
just something or get here in terms of I
know how you have my craziness but just
in terms of like me talking to like
Lindsay Price plays my wife and there
was that you weren't there about there
was a moment we were in the car and
we're driving we're doing a scene right
and we were just talking between and
there was such a comfortable kind of a
feeling with her and usually I'm I don't
become friends or I even versus like
people necessarily but with this show
you can tell that if it continues that
it'll be you know mean good relation oh
yes we all got we all got we all click
very quickly yeah it happened quickly
yeah it's nice when that happens yeah so
that in that way it's cool too but um
I'm just trying to let it go one scene
where you guys were the jogging scene
yeah yeah I think I told him to take a
beta blocker but I think he took like
four and he calls me in a panic he's
like PI I'm gonna be really busy and I
feel like I'm gonna and I seriously was
like should I call an ambulance
yeah yeah oh yeah I took those for a
minute I took beta blockers for a minute
you did because I went through a period
of about a year and a half where I was I
just lose my [ __ ] like I'd go into an
audition and I would lose my [ __ ]
mind and I'd forget everything and
my mouth would dry up and I'd be like I
would ruin my entire [ __ ] and so I yeah
it's not you know I just want to tell
people listening that I'm not weak I
have tell it's the opposite yeah yeah
opposite a weak you're a sensitive actor
yeah yeah who wants to please and when
you don't you get all [ __ ] up but it's
not just that though you have to
understand that I don't come from the
culture of acting right right
Robb's right and then one day you know
your agent goes why don't you try acting
and there you go oh then all of a sudden
you're in a room and you have to act
right no training never done it before
right and then you continue and they you
know it's like what my old sponsor used
to say you fake it to you're making
right but I'm always faking it I think
we all were I understand that but you
look at somebody like like Lindsey so
good right she's money
she's money right and then you're you
know you're I play her husband so you're
in a scene with her you know and you
could tell she's in it right and I'm
looking at her and I'm out I'm supposed
to be my next line but I'm looking at
him like oh but I but I do have to say
though so when we shot the pilot and
what they do is they test the pilot in
front of a bunch of test audience and
they've got these dials and it's such an
archaic way to sort of tell whether
their show is good or not but every
actors tested meaning you know we loved
Oliver or we didn't like this person
with a BA being tested the highest of
all of the actors but everyone loved
Bobby the most loved Bobby the mo I'm
out
why because most comfortable in the pain
yeah here's the thing here's the thing
though but let me say this yeah let me
say this my friend okay if the show
becomes a hit which I think it could be
I don't want to jinx it
yeah but I didn't you know you know Neal
Brennan you know Neal Neal Brennan if
you don't know he's a stand-up but he
also created the Chappelle show he
directs a lot of things Neal came up to
me at the store of four days ago and he
said hey can I talk to you and I go yeah
and he goes that thing you're in I go
what thing love no he goes that Network
thing that you're in with Oliver and
Jenna I go yeah he goes that could stay
on for a while mm-hmm and I go because
he's he's what he's seen me do a bunch
of [ __ ] over the years he's never said
anything
congratulations but not yeah he
literally sat me down and he said and
I'll tell you why it's relatable you go
it's a great cast it's seen it just
seems like it should be on right and I
also think that just given the climate
it's just something that we would rather
see family show and got a lot of heart I
want to watch anything politically
driven it's just something that gives
off its it's what I feel good [ __ ] right
what I say what the show was when I
during the pilot I equated it with a
band
do you remember Zeppelin no the Eagles
all right I'll tell you why the Eagles
came in the early 70s right but it was
during the tail end of the Vietnam War
the country was he just in a depression
not financially but just it was gloomy
you know you asked the JFK assassination
after Martin Luther King all that stuff
right so the Eagles comes along
this is kind of like this optimistic you
know there there are you know southern
kind of rock but take it easy yeah happy
just relaxing positive kind of music and
people gravitated toward it because it
was just to escape what was going on I
think in many ways splitting up together
eagles well alright I saw you laughing
George [ __ ] you alright you piece of
[ __ ] alright I'm not saying it in some
grandiose way that we're like the [ __ ]
on all I'm saying is is that it is a
light you know cute really kind of a
positive kind of a show and it's not
yeah we don't talk about politics or you
know really none of the social issues or
you know we're just real people well
we're also touching upon a subject
matter that has been going on for a
long-ass time people do have been doing
this forever but no one's shown it or
talked about it we haven't seen this in
any sort of medium really and I think
people I mean everyone I tell the
logline to oh this is what the show is
about they say oh my god well that's
relevant I mean my life that's my life
right no somebody yeah
or whatever it is and it no one's ever
sort of shown what we're showing you
brought in this show you know so people
are gonna I think people I think I've
only seen one you've seen how many four
they're good they're good okay they're
good that's all I care about
they're really good and I think this is
gonna be great for you I do because you
were talking about how yours ala you're
a comedian yeah I've never been an actor
and this yeah you're doing things in
this show that show a completely
different side that's what people
probably have never seen that one scene
we did the pilot yeah you know we had we
had a beat a moment where you have where
you have a line by saying well maybe
she's maybe she you should do this and
maybe you should do that and it's
sincere and it's real yeah it's dramatic
that's what that's all yeah I've never
done no one sees you like this
know what your butthole looks like no
idea how you are as an act the 2:10 have
babies never seen my butthole oh you've
never seen his button no I've never seen
it shown in my bought whole answer no
not yet not yet because you gave me that
compliment I'm gonna give you a gift I
will take this right here this right
here isn't a secure our flesh leg and
they molded her vag right here right and
it's all it's got all that stuff in here
and it's got um that the the material is
very vaginal like
[Music]